ha sido objeto de mucha especulación en
los últimos días pero El misterioso
globo que sobrevuela a Estados Unidos
Fue reclamado por Beijing como propio el
Ministerio de relaciones exteriores de
China dice que es un dispositivo
utilizado para fines de investigación
meteorológica que se había desviado de
su curso debido a los vientos Beijing
lamentó lo que calificó de violación
involuntaria del espacio aéreo
estadounidense china es un país
responsable que siempre ha acatado
estrictamente las leyes internacionales
y no tiene intención de violar el
territorio y el espacio aéreo de ningún
país soberano el globo había sobrevolado
la costa de Alaska y atravesado Canadá
antes de entrar a Estados Unidos el
pentágono sospecha que es un globo de
vigilancia a gran altitud que sobrevuela
lugares sensibles para recoger
información pero se abstenido de
derribar el objeto debido a los riesgos
de seguridad por la caída de restos el
incidente ha tensado aún más las
relaciones entre Estados Unidos y china
en un momento decrecientes tensiones y
el secretario de estado Anthony blinken
ha pospuesto su viaje diplomático a
previsto para las conversaciones sobre
Taiwán la presencia de este globo de
vigilancia en el espacio aéreo
estadounidense es una Clara violación de
la soberanía de Estados Unidos y del
derecho internacional es un acto
irresponsable la decisión de la
República Popular de China de llevar a
cabo esta acción en vísperas de mi
visita prevista va en detrimento de las
conversaciones que estábamos dispuestos
a mantener afirma que Estados Unidos
seguirá manteniendo abiertas las líneas
de comunicación con china sobre este
asunto y que el viaje seguirá adelante
cuando las condiciones lo permitan